joining me here on this episode of just
getting started the special nfl voices
tranche of podcasts that we've been
putting out ever since the season kicked
off is the voice of the nfl on cbs none
other than gymnast how are you jim i am
doing really well so excited to have the
season
here right before us now and uh ready to
get back to some football yeah me too no
question about that and uh
let's just jump right into the the
subject matter here which is origin
stories and how careers began and how
careers have evolved and let's get
started with yours how did you just get
started gymnasts
well formally it got started when i was
in college but conceptually it starts
when you're a kid and i think a lot of
people can relate to this
began with a big dream a dream when i
was 11 years old
for some reason that was about the time
it began to click in that these voices
that were coming into my living room on
weekends i was completely enchanted by
all of them enraptured i wanted to be
one of those storytellers
i i just
was hopelessly in love with
the way that they took me to places
around the world that uh seemed far away
and not even real
and uh i nurtured it that that dream and
went to college to try to pursue it and
then thankfully in college uh
there was a few things that would i
guess would fall under the category of
serendipity but a lot of it you have to
make your own breaks as we all have rich
and
i got started when i was at the
university of houston
and i went to houston with one goal that
was the one day figured out a way to be
discovered by cbs
not just any network yet i would have
taken any network obviously but the goal
was to work for cbs
and anyone that knows me since i was a
little boy knows that that was the dream
i love cbs because i love the way that
they presented the nfl that was back in
the old old days of ray scott and
jack buck was a
was a
play-by-play announcer at cbs of course
pat sumrall and frank glieber
and uh these were my heroes and on top
of it the allure to cbs was the fact
that i love the way cbs presented golf
and specifically the masters tournament
and that to me seemed like the ultimate
canvas
for
a storyteller to paint the picture and
to
be able to try to hone his craft that to
me was the hook cbs the nfl
and the masters
so the voices coming into your life when
you were a kid were cbs announcers that
caused you to want to put that jacket on
that cvs sports jacket well i just i
just mentioned a few but it broadened
out because abc was in a golden era of
television too
now when i was 11 jack whitaker was over
at cbs so he was another one of those
voices i mentioned with
with sumrall and scott and buck
and gleber
but
i
i just loved the way again these master
storytellers brought these events to
life
it wasn't ever a hook for me rich to be
on television to this day i could care
less if they ever put us on camera i'm
there to tell the story enjoy the game
and
try to do it jointly with a great
partner sitting next to me in this case
this season of course is tony romo again
and jim mckay was a huge influence on my
my life and my career chris schenkel
all of these men that i have mentioned
keith jackson
kurt gowdy
dick inberg i got to know them all i'm
sure you got to know them all and in
some cases i got to know them at a very
high level i got to deliver eulogies at
jack whitaker's funeral at jim mckay's
funeral
my life would go from a kid who was
writing letters to them
when i was in my teens even my early
teens writing them letters and sometimes
hearing back from them
to
later in life you grow up and
now you have
not only their mentorship but you have a
relationship that's so authentic and
real
that when it comes time to say our
goodbyes and those have been painful
times in my lives
uh my life i've been given the
opportunity been asked to stand up and
and and try to put together some words
about their their lives and their
careers
the journey indeed no question about
that so
let's uh i guess
rewind back to the breaks that you said
that happened in college what happened
at the university of houston that uh
that springboarded well i worked for a
campus radio station kuhf which is k
university of houston you know
proud of my school i love my school uh
like you love yours
and that gave me a press credential to
bring back from the
sporting events audio tape that they
could then insert the sound bites into
their into their newscast the next day
the credential was gold i wasn't paid
anything it was just an opportunity to
go sit in the press box
see big time sporting events all the big
leagues college events etc etc
meet them important media members in
houston
and watch how the big big time guys that
were coming in for the networks how they
in fact prepared and presented their
shows i would see them i'd be hanging
around in the in the in the press box
but one break that happened for me rich
is uh
my sophomore year in school you know i
was masquerading as a golfer i roomed i
was on the golf team i actually lettered
one year but that was not the passion
the passion was to get to cbs
but
my all of my roommates made it on the
pga tour
um blaine mcallister in fact won five
tour events
and freddie couples of course
uh has had a hall of fame career and i
got to be his uh presenter at the hall
of fame all of them my amigos were best
of friends to this day
they believed in my dream
they did everything to help nurture it
and make it seem possible plausible so
one day
in may of 1979
we went out to watch the you know the
the houston open golf tournament
four guys from the university houston
golf team go out to watch you know the
big stars of the pga tour they all want
to be that
out there one day and they all made it
but as we were walking by the 17th hole
i looked over and saw the nbc sports
compound
and uh
one of them nudged me and said you want
to go over and ask
for a job
i said no
i i don't have any experience that's not
going to happen but i tell you it's not
a bad idea i should i should uh look up
don ohlmeyer why i'm here who's don
ohmeyer i said well he's the big guy
that runs in bc sports and he produces
their he produces their golf
how do you know that well you know read
the credits come on guys i mean i'm
studying this
so you go ask goldmire but you got to
meet him you got to meet him so it was
on a friday i didn't know if he was
going to be on site or not they weren't
covering it until saturday but i went up
to a security guard with my mates and i
asked to see don ohlmeyer and the guy
said
who wants to see him
and i said tell him jim nance is here
yeah
got the security guard
we waited waited we thought he kind of
forgotten about us all of a sudden here
comes the security guy
with another man in tow it suddenly
dawned on me i didn't know what donald
meyer looked like
[Laughter]
did you have a cigarette jim
yeah of course he did
and a drink in the other hand uh
but a towering presence as you know sure
and uh he walks over and says hey i'm
looking for jim nance and i said yes sir
i'm right here now i've got to have some
confidence here and he said how can i
help you and i said well i'm a
university houston student i want to
work one day in network television these
are my roommates i introduced them all
and he's as and i said i was wondering
if there perhaps could be something i
could do this week and i was looking for
a job he said well what do you have in
mind
and with that one of them and i'm not
sure it was
john or fred or blaine one of them
blurted out he wants to be on the air
and omar kind of like
took a
almost spit out his cigarette said well
uh we have all the announcers we need
but
if you would be willing to work with us
this weekend i could find some things
for you to do
it wouldn't pay anything but i can get
your credential i'll tell you what it is
you know we're out here at 17
our announcers are parking up at the
clubhouse behind 18 green so i've got
some people helping shuttle them by cart
when they pull up
to start their day and they bring them
down to the compound and then at the end
of the day you would need to drive them
back to the parking lot
i thought you know what if i'm not going
to be on the air this might be the
second best job
this weekend
so uh it's amazing away we go and i
ended up being a runner for nbc that
week of course i had a lot of lag time
once i got the don quickies uh and the
john brodies of the world and bob
goldbee's uh
these were all the announcers lee
trevino once i got them safely to the
compound
um i
i just kind of hung around the trucks i
went in and invited myself to watch
olmeyer produce the show and then i
would thank him
saturday and sunday for the opportunity
but on sunday he said hey
kid you did a good job he said uh we're
doing the byron nelson next week
up to dallas says you want to come join
us
he said i'll even pay you
wow
he says yeah can you get there on friday
i said well my last final
is on friday morning
and i i can be there by like two o'clock
he says you've done here's who here's
the guy you call so i went up to dallas
and the next week he gave me a better
job i sat in a tower as a spotter
for a golfer named john schroeder
in the golf for years and was brilliant
and kind to me
but
they paid me 20 a day
which to me was a lot of money and i got
paid for friday for checking in so i got
paid 60 dollars to drive to dallas
now while i was there i thought i'm
going to double down
i'm going to call on some of these
people i've met in the press box and
tell them i'm up here in dallas and i
could do some free reports from the
byron nelson
some free radio reports and that i did
that
this is truly amazing so your
gymnast your first paying network
television gig which this technically is
nbc sports your first ever
paying gig in network television came
from you just cold calling if you will
with freddie couples and blaine
mcallister and your buddies
don olmeyer of nbc sports that is
true that is it
there's not one embellishment here
that's 100 facts and that was cool yeah
i got into it so to take it another step
uh cbs radio affiliate houston took me
up on that a great guy named dave
barrett and jerry trupiano they said
sure why not have at it i said i will
write some copy and you can it was like
an all-news format so i would
condense the days scoring down to like
second
uh voiceover
here at the byron nelson tom watson
leads the tournament after a second
round 67 you know i didn't have a lot of
experience doing this but i
sure sold them on the fact i could do it
and they aired it and at the at the end
of the weekend they invited me to come
by the station in houston and if i ever
wanted to come by they saw somebody was
enterprising and work as an unpaid
intern no credit hours you've got a job
so i did so by meeting olmeyer and guess
getting my first gig making 60
i doubled down on that and created a
position as again unpaid position at a
cbs radio station in houston and i ended
up working for ktrh until i was a
full-time television person upon
graduation
yeah in fact
i took the kcra freelancing or or
volunteering because i i've really
worked over 40 50 hours a week for them
and didn't get paid i was just
completely enamored with watching
uh these pros at work every day and
running coffee for them whatever i could
do jerry trupiano became later on the
astros and the oilers play by play man
but the
boston red sox huge mentor line
jerry uh ran the department and
you know he gave me all kinds of advice
along the way i ended up taking that
though getting an opportunity to
audition for a weekend
sports anchoring gig on the cbs tv
affiliate which i won
so now by my junior year in college i'm
volunteering at the radio station on the
cbs side and i'm actually on the air on
weekends
about every other weekend on channel 11
cbs in houston so yes i created
opportunity i did yeah
well you didn't just cr you you
you created them but you worked your
tail off to get
the next one and the next one and just
an insatiable
desire to reach your goal like a
singular mind i mean
does it ever dawn on you ever thought at
all
because you're such a positive person
but does it ever dawn at you at all like
what if you
didn't stroll past the 17th
hole at that houston open that day with
your friends like i mean like what
what hap what happened and then if
you're like yeah you know what i'm not
gonna tell them jim nancy said don't
tell you tell don omar jim nance is here
you know does that ever
hit you at all like what if you didn't
do such effort probably never would have
been in the business i don't know it
desperately tried to create some other
scenarios there's no choice
because i did have the
local radio of the campus radio station
but
the the
the backup plan was to go work with my
dad who was a furniture salesman he was
a wholesale furniture salesman who had
accounts in louisiana oklahoma and the
whole state of texas
it wasn't an easy life he was in his car
all the time calling on clients from new
orleans all the way to el paso and
midland and
tulsa and oklahoma city and all places
in between he traveled all the time
set in his car listening to radio
dreaming a lot dreaming for his son a
lot and
as an only son i knew that one day i
wanted to take
a lot of that off his plate and go to
work with my dad that would be fun to be
able to share the experience with my dad
so that was the plan if if i didn't get
a chance if i didn't feel like it was
realistic i was going to go down that
road of going into the family business
with my dad
pretty quickly
but you know i
i graduated from school
in 1981 and by this time i'm still
working for the the same radio station
that i called from dallas ktrh
and channel 11 both are cbs affiliates i
felt this cbs tug
and all of a sudden one day out of the
blue i got a head hunter who called me
about an opening in salt lake city
at a cbs station
here we go now i didn't know
i mean i knew it was beautiful but
i thought i'm not leaving houston top 10
market with all these big time sports to
go to utah that's how
uh
really i did i didn't have a handle on
the world i didn't have a good scope of
things i'm just young
but i thought i'm gonna go up there and
visit just to get some experience of the
interviewing process
so i
i took the the interview flew into salt
lake and looked around and thought this
is the most gorgeous place i've ever
seen
they actually had me prepare a sports
cast and i went in an audition did a
three or four minute sportscast met
everybody on the way back to the airport
to take me back to houston the sports
director there don judd offered me the
job said you passed every test for us
we'll we're going to offer you the job
it's gonna pay uh thirty six thousand
dollars a year plus we'll give you the
use of a car
i thought it was big i've gone to heaven
i went back home talked to my dad my mom
about it like how am i gonna leave
houston but
but i just got a really good feeling
about this station that ksl is a huge to
this day a giant influence in the salt
lake market really well-run station i
have great friends that are still there
so i went back and it was a leap of
faith but i thought i'm going to leave
houston and maybe that's a good thing is
to leave
and get another market experience so i
did i left
i left a year upon graduation
and went to salt lake city to to anchor
and to call utah jazz basketball games
that came with it with hot rod hundley
yes i was going to ask you who is in the
who's on the team the great hot rod
hundley who's
a broadcasting legend
who we just lost it was an incredible
gentle giant wonderful friend daryl
griffith ricky green eventually thorough
bailey john stockton great guys love
that franchise that's still the team i
root for the most because of my my ties
there
and just pulling up the story a little
bit two years later i got one of those
calls out of the blue again and i ended
up going to new york to audition for cbs
just about three a little more than
three years out of college who called
you from cbs sports the the dream the
dream call the one the call that like
walk me through
that call
for somebody that we've already
established on this pod here and
obviously
for your life here that the 11 year old
wanting this call and the call comes
walk me through that jim it was august
the 15th
of 1985
and i had just come in from playing in
the utah open pro-am
and i was gonna be doing my sportscast
that night
on
this was a thursday i was gonna do the
six and ten o'clock news sportscast and
i went through a pile of messages
one of which was from a guy from cbs
named ed
goran
your friend of mine
it was ed who called you huh it was ed
now listen
i
at the time i just assumed it was
cbs looking to put some packaging
together now i had had calls from cbs in
the past the bob mons box of the world
they go to their affiliates
and would ask back in those days for
b-roll for features they were doing hey
can you send us some byu
practice footage we need it for a story
we're doing so i i figured it was just
you know the courtesy that you do you
put you dub off some some highlights of
robbie bosco at quarterback and
you know you ship it overnight by fedex
yes but when i when when
ed uh answered my return call
he said
hey
we've been um
we've been watching your your sports
casts
recently
and we like what we see we have an
opening i'm sure you're aware of it
and i said no actually i'm not aware of
it
you didn't read about in the usa today i
said no see this was the early stages of
rudy martzke yesterday the usa today
which became kind of the
centerpiece of information flow what was
happening who was in who was out i
hadn't seen it so apparently
they were making a change that not not
apparently they were making a change
at the anchor position for the college
football studio the prudential college
football report
and
there was a guy that was a running favor
for it out of boston
and he was in a contract negotiation and
things were going sideways
and
bob lobel it was his job
and bob apparently asked for more money
or i don't know i don't want to
speculate but there's something broke
down in the negotiation
so on
august the 15th they called me
to say that in new york on saturday two
days later they were holding an audition
for five people
to be the studio anchor and we've
thought about it a lot we've watched
your work we know you're young and the
whole thing and we thought let's bring
the kid in from salt lake city i'm
paraphrasing here but that's kind of
what i i took out of it
so
yeah i meant i had to be on a plane the
next morning
i was a late edition
and
i was the number two anchor
at ksl our number one anchor the great
paul james
was was out of town on vacation so there
was no backup i was going to go like 10
straight nights of anchoring i found our
news director
spence canard and his assistant guy
named ernie ford
and i i told him that night i've got an
opportunity to go to new york and
audition
and i can still remember ernie saying to
me he said son
don't worry about it we'll figure out a
way to cover for you
that is never happened
you get on that plane tomorrow morning
and good luck we're proud of you and wow
the next morning western airlines flight
to jfk i couldn't believe it cbs sent a
car to pick me up at jfk i'm riding in
style you know this is like uh
you know i don't know what it's out of
beverly hillbillies or
or uh
it's hard work it's hard work paying off
and you getting your lottery ticket and
getting struck by lightning however you
want to put it but
you know i i i'm there are a lot of news
directors in our business who would have
told you too bad
too bad you're my guy
you're my guy i need you this is you
know this is your job that's not your
job this is your job
i hired you you know like
good for what was his name i mean
ford ultimately was the guy
who pulled that quick decision quick
trigger so lucky
yeah i went to new york
so i went to new york on that friday and
uh ed and patty
uh
we're hosting a dinner at the russian
tea room for the finalists it's kind of
strange you're gonna sit around the
table with all those guys you're
competing against of course i'm just i'm
just happy to be
noticed i don't expect to get this job
then i find out the other finalists are
pat hayden who was auditioning to be the
anchor
uh
an unbelievable friend of mine to this
day sure um
a guy named fred weimore who had made it
to wcbs in new york out of sacramento he
was the weekend anchor in new york
james brown
wow jp
and roy firestone who was the
anchor there at kcbs in los angeles
so you got
two guys from l.a pat and roy you got
jb from dc you got a guy from new york
wymore you got some kid
wet behind the ears from salt lake city
who's just excited that he got to fly
first class because cbs sent him a first
class ticket and i got to ride a limo
into the city to his hotel
so
we went to dinner uh at the russian tea
room and i didn't get the chance to say
a whole lot
but uh they gave us the rundown the
order of how it was going to go the next
day and i was going to be fifth the
fifth and final one
and uh that next morning of course it
was a sleepless night got all prepped to
go down to the cbs broadcast center and
i realized i had not packed the tie
okay in my haste
so i could still the shop is still there
on um
seventh avenue i ran in and bought a tie
skinniest car you ever saw in your life
just awful uh and i showed up to the
broadcast center and i i went in and
performed the audition and on my
audition
it was two segments of scores and
highlights which you were not allowed to
prepare for they gave you like 15
minutes with a deck of cards and
highlight sheets for you to kind of
quickly go through it and the third
segment they said you're going to be
interviewing a college football expert
so i didn't know what that meant
so i figured the scores were going to
kind of come out rapidly they'd be
moving them along they were being shown
in a
rear projection screen behind me i could
see myself on camera at the same time i
could see the scores over my shoulder i
had never worked that way we never had
that ability in salt lake to work where
you'd see yourself
so um
i i knew there were going to be some
scores that would come out upside down
just to see how it would handle all of a
sudden they're out of order and how you
would get the train back on the tracks i
was mentally prepared for that and i
felt like i smoothly handled that
and at the end of the second scoring
segment ed said in my ear throw it to
commercial promising mike francesa
coming up next
stop
who's mike frances
so i threw at the conversion audition
part of your audition and there's our
actual prudential commercial running and
all of a sudden now behind the back here
comes a guy walks up shakes a hand he's
obviously from new york hey i'm mike
francesa yes i said hi jim nancy said
ask me anything you want about college
football i said anything anything
so stand by 10 seconds the commercial
ends wide shot welcome back i'm here
with mike frances who knows everything
about college football mike let's start
with the heisman who are the favorites
this year in the heisman race he went
through all that i asked about
conferences and this and then eventually
had said take us off the air thank mike
and throw it back to the game mike thank
you great insight we'll be back with the
second half as we continue here on cbs
in just a moment boom
finished it
as
they dipped the black out of the control
room suddenly comes a whole parade of
people ted shaker
who had a huge part in this decision to
hire me it was great to me still is duke
struck the director ed goran they came
out they were giddy eyed you know they
were like wide-eyed like wow
how did you how did you feel that how
did you feel that went i said well
it felt a little rough i mean
i i think i could have done better they
said
wow well you didn't make a mistake i
said well thank you and then
teddy pointed to a monitor over my
shoulder cbs was on the air
with uh with a horse race at the time
and he said you remind me a lot of that
guy pointing over my shoulder i turned
around to see their i guess been a quick
camera cut and there was a shot of one
of the racing analysts at the time a guy
named frank wright
and i said i remind you a lot of frank
wright he says nope that's good that you
know who he is no that guy i turn around
it's brent he says you remind me a lot
of him i said bro
yes i said that's that's quite a
compliment he said it is
just right to the point it is
he said you think you could do this for
real
i said uh you mean the job he's
said
well if i had more time to prep i think
i could be better than what i showed you
today like would i have the chance to
prepare during the week all week long
we'd have a whole team of people behind
you it should be easier but you think
you can handle the live element of it
national television i said i think i can
he said good
good ed's gonna go out to dinner with
you
and we'll be back in touch so that night
ed took me to dinner
and said that
you know things had gone well and he
said i can tell you this how old are you
again they had asked me that several
times 26
and i think they just couldn't get to
past the fact that a kid from salt lake
even though i felt like my foundation
was from houston could just walk in and
maybe handle
the pressure of national television
so he said we're gonna you're gonna your
your life changed today
on the 17th of august 1985.
you are going to be either the guy
that's going to get this job
or we're going to put you in one of our
owns which would be new york at the time
new york chicago la
i believe kmox and st louis might have
been an illinois at the time and uh cau
in philadelphia so i knew that night
that
i was gonna be making a step i didn't
know i was gonna actually get the job
and ultimately they just decided to give
me the job and pat ended up coming on
board as is kind of a co-anchor more of
an analyst but as a co-anchor
and then jb obviously jb he ended up
getting hired within you know he was
working part-time for cbs on some nba
coverage and things like that and became
a staple and treasure team right shortly
on fox 2 and then back to cbs where he
is currently today tossing to you and
you to him on the biggest games on cbs
it really is amazing
i do want to you know i know our
just have a few minutes left here with
you jim but how did you get to the tower
and the masters in 1986 you're hired in
80 so you're hired in 85
and then you're here here's one i just
thought of this when i left to go to
salt lake and all these calls were
coming in freddie couples was staying at
my condominium in salt lake he was
playing in a tournament out there
so
i asked him
like how would i handle this
you know this going to be like it could
be life changing you know freddy's the
coolest guy of all time there's a lot
more internally going on and fire and
anxiety than the world ever knew i knew
it but i was asking how did he disguise
it he said just keep telling yourself
it's no big deal it's no big deal he
said when i'm over a shot i just keep
saying in my head so it's just on a loop
it's no big deal it's no big deal so
when i was in there auditioning i just
kept saying it's no big deal it's no big
deal i sat at a chair on the nfl today
desk there was the chair that on the
back had a piece of tape that had
somebody written in a sharpie brent i
was sitting in brent mussberger's chair
i watched the nfl today for years
by the way you got to read this book
coming up uh i think it's released
october 1st
uh
rich podolski is writing a book called
you are looking live about the history
of the nfl today
i'm all in on that but i um yeah you
gotta have them on your show so
i
i had
this dream sequence that
i had actually been through that dream
sequence so much since i was 11 that
there was a certain calmness for me
being there because i felt like i had
been there before in my mind then
coupled with freddy telling me it's no
big deal it's no big deal it's no big
deal so it's just a pretty cool thing
that freddy was in my life
when i was in school nurturing the dream
and there he was when i was leaving to
new york and coming back and now my
life's never going to be the same and
you know i ended up getting i ended up
getting the job oh
here you go so this is august in
september fred's attending the u.s open
tennis tournament
he loves sports he ranted to frank
turkinian who was the father of golf
television and freddie knew him because
freddie ardy was a star on the tour and
and you know frank knew all the young
players and frank went up to him and
said hey
this kid we just hired a guy that uh cbs
who says he knows you jim nance and fred
says i know you did he said does he know
anything about golf he said well he was
my roommate and teammate he said good
freddy anxiously called me right back
said frank you're kenny was just asking
about you he's going to roll for you so
i knew if i didn't screw up the football
too much there might be
golf in the offing and in fact i ended
up hosting
a few months after football the final
four for the first time this whole
studio operation
through the 86 tournament including the
final four
so that was a big gig for a kid still 26
and then you know i showed up at the
masters uh the week after that for the
first time
and i've been there now 36 years and i
got to tell you it's just as sweet now
walking uh onto the ground to the god
store or being at the final four or
being in the studio or putting on the
cbs jacket now as it was 36 years ago
but you were in the 16th tower right
well jack when jack
hit that famed
shot trying to win that masters that he
did at the age that he was that famed
moment where
what his his who was his cat he was it
his son son jackie jack was adding for
him and and uh he had a six iron that
spun off the hill and it rolled just
past the cup and nearly fairly very
nearly went in for an ace
and uh ended up making the putt at that
point to tie the lead and i
said something about the bear
has come out of hibernation
and i don't know where the line came
from in fact i
concerned myself worried myself that
maybe it had already been said by
someone else on the broadcast thankfully
it hadn't again i was just trying to
earn a ticket back for the 87 masters
um and gloriously for me um and i've
been going back every year since i'm i'm
grateful
yeah that's the famed story where jack
hits the shot and he's picking up the t
and he hears his
is i guess this is true he hears his son
say be the right stick and he goes it is
yeah
get be close but jack's not even
watching he's picking the tea out of the
ground and says it is
with jack last month we were recounting
that story we did a couple of events
together out in pebble
um
i love the man he's 81 years old now and
he's uh
he's very aware that my first masters
was his epic sixth green jacket and i
just feel what a way to come in
to golf
to be able to see the curtain call the
encore performance by
the greatest winningest champion in the
history of the game and then to be able
to document all the other eras and of
course most notably tigers
and the next generation to come
well i i'm wrapping this up jim i i just
want to say this just hearing your story
i i didn't know a lot of what you just
said
um and
for me i i got to espn at age 26
and i'm gonna tell the story of my uh of
my of my audition after i say goodbye at
the end of this pod here
but um
it was very similar in the fact that
i've i i felt like i had belonged i
didn't have that phrase in my head of no
big deal but i had i did have some sort
of mechanism no i did to try and get
that job through that audition then i
was 26
there and then you know i i
it was kind of a shocker to me
parting ways and a lot of that was
management and a lot of that was
my belief in myself and what they were
not offering me but that's that's
neither here nor there but my first gig
after
leaving sports when i got a call on my
honeymoon from tony petit of cbs sports
offering me the job to do the late night
highlight show of the us open on cbs
that they shoehorned in between
letterman and kilbourne for a couple of
weeks and
and i got that jacket that cbs sports
jacket and i've never shared this with i
never really had an opportunity to or a
forum to and i'm going to do it here i
had that jacket when i put that jacket
on i
i thought of you
i really didn't that i was representing
you and and i'm serious i was repping
you in this gold standard
organization of sports
and
and then you know but i also was doing
a lot of you know comedy and stuff and
having fun because it was late night
which is maybe one of part of the reason
why they hired me but it was very unus
open tennis-like stuff
and
i i was concerned about whether this was
working or not or
the right thing or not and about a week
into the tournament
you showed up i guess just as a patron
but you you came to the back you came to
the green room in the production room
and you said hello to me and you told me
i was doing a great job i don't know if
you remember this or not but you told me
you know
you this what you told me and and it
meant so
much to me thank you i've never met you
before yeah and um and the fact that i
can have you on a show like this call
you up and be able to call you a friend
which is i know a very true very true
you know
it's a power of words
it's a testament to what you say you
might think it doesn't stick
the fact that that stuck with you that
that means a lot to me i uh i think we
all have to be
mindful
you know when you're 26 now you weren't
26 obviously this is late in your career
when you're 26 you'd think that you're
mature enough to be able to handle all
this
and you're disguising a lot of it
i think i mean i i think that we're not
as worldly as we thought we were
um and it takes um
you know takes a lot of internal
confidence but you don't want to be
overconfident
and i i'm kind of now that i'm in my 60s
i'm amazed that i got fortunate enough
to be able to get those opportunities
and i'm just grateful for all the people
along the way
whether it was donald meyer who was
hugely helpful or ed goren picking up
the phone and call me or ted shaker and
all the other people that i mentioned
you know i remember what they say it's
interesting andrew marchand yesterday on
a
nfl seminar conference call asked me to
name some of the really young
play-by-play announcers i see out there
who make an impression on me
and i said you know what
i'm not going to do that because if i
leave someone out it's going to hurt
someone's feelings yeah because there's
so much talent out there i can remember
keith jackson
got the lifetime emmy and it was pretty
early in my career and i was sitting in
the audience that night i didn't know
keith all that well
but he talked about the next generation
of broadcasters and he rattled off a few
names he mentioned me
that was like one of the greatest things
ever in my life that keith jackson
actually
mentioned me now had he not
i i probably at that point would have
thought
man i'm not that good or
i haven't been noticed or i'm way behind
or you know it's we all have somewhere
deep inside some some fragile egos that
you're never quite sure how other people
see you does that make sense you know of
course yeah so question
i i refused yesterday to answer that
question there's so many gifted people
we have this uh award that
a guy
named joe chiles nick named
the college sports broadcast of the year
after me
and it's now 11 years in the making and
there are 11 different great young
broadcasters uh who have won the award
it's they call it the college sports
broadcasting heisman i'm so honored to
have my name on it because i was like
you were we were one of them
i actually feel
worse for the ones that don't win it
because there's a group of finalists
there's top 20 rankings you can see it
all online it's amazing what they do but
i've had a friendship and a relationship
with virtually every one of the winners
and they're all doing great they're all
breaking in getting their chances and um
thank you i just i'll leave you with
this just thank you for letting me
reminisce i had to dust off some of the
cobwebs a little bit no it's great
but rich you are a great friend and uh
thanks jim our careers have had a very
parallel path um i'm proud to say and uh
we still have a ways to go and i'm like
i know that
i know that and i i love that advice i
assume that's the best piece of advice
you've received in your career no no big
deal
from uh from couples yeah imagine that
yeah that ranks up there no question it
did um don't make more out of things
than they are even though your career is
riding on it
the world still
you know will go on
and the old sun will come up tomorrow
line that cliche is true and we have ups
and downs we've had moments we would
love to have back all of us in our
careers
and you know time helps take care of it
there's a lot of highs or some lows
uh but there's a never-ending
major major reservoir of gratitude
and that's where i'm coming from
jim nance you are the best thanks for
being on this episode of just getting
started and being part of this uh we
couldn't have a uh
a a segments uh a group of uh podcasts
on nfl voices without you thank you hey
thank you for including me rich i'll see
you out in l.a okay
that's jim nance right here on just
getting started
what a great chat with jim nance right
there and just hearing his
story
about his
audition
in new york city when he was in
a guy from
salt lake i guess from out there in utah
and how
he couldn't believe that his fortunes
had landed him
in
uh
in a network studio with all these big
executives who were telling them that
they
were interested in him for their network
job
and how overwhelmed he was at the notion
and how
he couldn't believe his good fortune i
i
it struck me because i felt the same
exact way
when i did my audition for espn when i
was in redding california
and got a phone call at work and i
apologize if i'm retelling stories that
i've already told on this podcast before
because
you know
uh we're we're several in and
and uh i forget what i've said already
to be honest with you and also you know
um
these stories overlap and experiences
overlap but i was sitting in my
um
my
newsroom at the sports desk in redding
california the abc affiliate that i was
working for
i think out of the 200 some odd metered
markets in the united states which is
this is like
market this number
120 or something at any rate
there was a phone on the desk
and the phone on the desk from my desk
it would ring once
if it was a local call
and it would go ring ring if it was a
call from outside the area code
i've never had a phone like that before
this is 1995
and
this phone existed in my world and it
would go ring ring only when like my
parents called from new jersey
or my brother called from southern
california that was basically it
i mean my friends when they would want
to reach me would not call me at work
so i'm sitting at my desk and it was
ring ring and i pick it up and it was a
an agent named henry riesch
from william morris talent agency
telling me
that he had heard i was one of the
hottest up and coming sportscasters in
america
and can
i send him my
my reel my tape that i'd sent to
headhunters
around the country
these three search firms that
networks could
find talent through where they would
just look at these reels of
sportscasters from around the country
and i sent mine to three headhunters
figuring what does it cost just first
class postage
and i'm like i couldn't believe that
this guy had said this and i i'm like if
you say so that i'm hot and cup and
coming because i'm about to drive you
know about an hour into these mountains
here in northern california to go cover
a high school volleyball game like
i'm not feeling very hot but of course i
didn't say that to this guy i'm like
okay like what's your address and i took
his address and i'm like how can i
follow up you know i took his phone
number i wasn't gonna let this guy go
and i immediately hung up the phone and
looked around and thought was i being
punked
and um no and i called my brother
and
my brother
you know couldn't believe
that this happened for me too because he
knew what my dream was to get to espn
and 10 minutes later the phone ring ring
again
like that's two ring rings two outside
calls like this like did he call my
parents and they calling me now i mean
like who could it be and i thought said
to myself watch i am such hot [ __ ]
that's espn on the phone and it was al
jaffe
from espn who is the chief talent
coordinator
for espn the guy who found all the
sportscenter anchors that was on the air
and
you know from kilbourn all the way to
you name it al jaffe
was the
was the talent hunter for espn who i'd
sent
so many unsolicited resumes and tapes
too with no response it was al
and i thought like did my brother put
this guy up to
[Music]
you know like friend of mine say call
rich he say you're out jaffe he'll he'll
he'll
he'll buy it you know you can really
screw with his head
and i almost dropped the mf bomb on him
i said you know who is this emma you
know
i didn't thankfully and it was really al
jaffe who invited me down to los angeles
to meet with executives a few weeks
later and i did and i just remember
flying down to l.a and meeting them and
one executive after another came down
from an upstairs as a lobby of a hotel
the um which is now the sls hotel in los
cienega boulevard in los angeles and
um
you know it was um
out of body experience one executive
after another interviewing me for
sportscenter like wow
i couldn't believe this was happening
and eventually we booked a time for me
to fly to bristol for a um
for an audition
and i couldn't believe that either and
my head was just spinning and my heart
was
bumping out of my chest for those weeks
waiting for that time as i'm going about
my business driving around
reading california with my
big camera and
huge tape deck and doing you know the
one-man band operation in a small outfit
thinking could i really go from here to
espn is that possible did i just get win
the lottery
and i flew east for the audition and got
as far as chicago before
one of the biggest snowstorms in the
history of the 90s hit the east coast
and i couldn't get into connecticut and
i had to turn around and go back
and i remember thinking to myself oh my
god
did i just lose this opportunity will i
ever reschedule like what happens like
could this
could this have happened could i be like
the moonlight graham here you know like
i had my one shot and it didn't work out
and now i'm gonna
never get a chance at espn but sure
enough
i i um i got another shot and i flew out
two weeks later
and i remember getting into espn and i'm
i couldn't believe this was gonna happen
and it was on a sunday i flew in and
monday was my audition
and i was in the radisson hotel across
the street from espn
which is to use the al michaels phrase
uh he always would refer to substandard
hotels as a two and a half seasons or a
one and a half seasons instead of a four
seasons this was about a one season
hotel
and to the point where
uh you know the person upstairs as i'm
trying to get some sleep the night
before
i could hear the person urinating in the
toilet upstairs through the thin ceiling
like that's a true story as i like i
couldn't get any sleep that night and i
could hear the guy
uh you know i'm assuming it had to be a
man
because you just heard the flowing water
uh the guy's peeing flushing the toilet
it was insane i i i hardly slept a wink
that night but what i definitely did do
before going to sleep is i watched
sportscenter
the 11 o'clock sportscenter on a sunday
night back in that day in the mid 90s
was the the height of the big show with
dan patrick and keith olbermann
and i remember watching it
and thinking to myself how i would do
the highlight if
if
i was the one doing the highlights
that's the way i did it i'm like i'm
going to do my homework i'll practice
doing highlights by saying i would have
done it this way i'd have done it that
way even though keith and dan do it
perfectly and i just remember that there
was a highlight of
um
of a basketball
game grant hill was doing something and
you know against
jordan maybe you know pistons and bulls
or whatever
and um they used it as like a
tic-tac-toe board so
uh for instance grand hill would do a
great highlight and they would put like
a grand hill face on the top left part
of a tic-tac-toe board jordan made a
good play it would be jordan in the
middle of the board and it was just a
highlight produced by somebody who
wanted to do something different right
and it was just grand hill and michael
jordan highlights and they made it seem
like they were playing a game of
tic-tac-toe and it wound up being a draw
and i just remember saying to myself
since i was such a big hollywood squares
game show fan i would instead of instead
of saying well let's put grand hill in
that square and we'll put michael jordan
that square i would have said a phrase
from the back in the day i'll take
rosemary for the block
you know
because one of the
highlights was somebody blocking a shot
and then i would say oh that's not
rosemary that's so-and-so
and um
i just that's what i was thinking i
would have done it this would have done
it that way so next day wake up it's
time to do the audition
and i show up and i'm in the newsroom of
espn and there's
you know
uh like gary miller was doing
sportscenter at the time and i'm like
looking around where's dan where's keith
right like where's berman just like sort
of stargazing in a way can't believe i'm
here and i'm like how does this happen
and
you know
um they told me get ready for the show
here's your rundown of the highlights
and i'm like rundown like i used to
create my own rundown at reading i
didn't have a rundown i used to wrote no
one created one for me i did it myself
and also the the i worked the um
the
teleprompter myself with a foot pedal
that we would pass underneath the desk
from the news anchor to the sports
anchor when it was time for sports the
news anchor would just shove with their
foot the foot pedal to me underneath the
desk and you would give it some gas to
work the the prompter
at your own speed and they told me
someone else was going to work the
prompter for me and if i put the copy in
for my lead-ins they would work the
prompter for me and i'm like okay great
but deep down inside i'm like this is
amazing people do stuff for you here you
don't have to do it all yourself but the
saving grace of it was the highlights
that they were going to use in my
audition were the same highlights from
the dan and keith sports center the
night before unbeknownst to me
me watching that show and going through
the
motions of what i would have done
with the highlights
now i actually get to put it into
practice for my
audition i had unbeknownst to me
rehearsed my audition the night before
sitting in that radisson listening to
the person peeing upstairs
so i was ready
i was ready and i was like psyched i
like do you want to see the highlights
before and i'm like sure i'll take a
look at them just to make sure it was
the same highlights that i saw and i was
scrolling through the you know scrubbing
through the tapes which they were tapes
at the time i'm like oh my god i've seen
this before i know what i'm going to say
and i went downstairs and i killed the
audition and in the same way that nance
had the executives like ed gordon come
out smiling from ear to ear saying good
job
because not only do they think they had
their man but it also confirmed their
abilities to spot talent in the eyes of
whoever their bosses are
that when i was done
with my audition al jaffe came out from
the control room big smile on his face
saying great job and he's chuckling he
goes rosemary for the block that's a
great line
and i'm like yeah baby i got the job
and i did
and that's the story of my espn audition
that you know
a lot of dumb luck a lot of hard work a
lot of preparation a lot of thoughts of
you know don't get any rest watch the
show get ready for it maybe these are
the things that you can do
get your mind ready and i actually
inadvertently
prepared for my audition before i did it
amazing
i can't believe that happened and nance
telling that story it's just like the
same thing i did and i was age 26 just
like jim
um so i want to thank my friend who came
on the show and did a little hello
friends with me and um i want to thank
you for taking in this latest edition of
just getting started
more to come right here on this podcast
don't you dare
do anything except subscribe so you
could hear all of the episodes prior to
this one with jim dance
right here on just getting started
you